bomb Cyclone it's just another term for
explosive cyclogenesis a bomb Cyclone is
an area of low pressure it deepens
within a certain period of time so it's
not a hurricane or anything like that
but it is a very intense storm system
basically a cyclone just means a
rotating storm system a bomb Cyclone is
when an area of low pressure drops 24
millibars within 24 hours so if you
speak specifically about the wine in
North America part what happened was you
had all the conditions line up to make
this The Perfect Storm so you've got
Arctic air that slung all the way down
to Mexico basically it stretched six
thousand kilometers from White Horse to
Mexico City all the ingredients were
there the bitter cold meeting up with
that warmer air sparking the low a
center of an area of low pressure forms
and it was able to intensify within a
short period of time meeting that
definition for a bond sector which is if
a bomb has been dropped going off in
terms of weather so you're getting
lashed with everything but it's just a
vigorous system that's happening all at
once so weather Bond
is another word for it weather bomb bomb
Cyclone
explosive psychogenesis there's just so
many terms being thrown around about
this you know particular setup maybe the
result of seeing more weather bombs is
certainly a factor of you know climate
change and that you have all these
different variables and they all are
extreme right because you look at even
this weather system how extreme the cold
was how extreme the snow was we were
talking blizzard conditions white out
zero visibility in some spots I mean
this was pretty incredible stuff it's
just an example of these extremes that
are becoming almost you know monthly or
in some cases weekly daily events like
you know we need to keep tabs on